the new bachelor is revealed chase  mcnairy and luke pail of Joe Joe  Fletcher season were frontrunners even  confirming they were in talks but on  Tuesday nights after paradise the big  announcement was a big surprise  you  yes Nick Viall is the bachelor the 35  year old was a contestant twice on The  Bachelorette during andi dorfman hand  Kaitlyn Bristowe seasons I've had an  interesting journey throughout this  process it hadn't worked out so far and  hopefully this time around um maybe  things will end up on a more positive  and he's been a total stand out on this  season of bachelor in paradise you seem  very happy yeah I'm happy how are you  feeling Nick's witty remarks wise words  I hope this is an opportunity for Ashley  to demonstrate some maturity and growth  and a totally ripped body have us  thinking he couldn't be a better choice  but what do you think let us know on  twitter at ET now